we're asked to multiply the complex
number one minus 3i times the complex
number two plus 5i and the general idea
here is you can multiply these complex
numbers like you would have as like you
would have multiplied any traditional
binomial you just have to remember that
this isn't a variable this is the
imaginary unit I or it's just I but we
could do that in two ways we could just
do the distributive property twice which
I like a little bit more just because it
actually you're doing it from a
fundamental principle it's nothing new
or you could use foil which you also use
when you multiple you first multiply
binomials and I'll do it both ways so
you could view you could this is just a
number one minus 3i and so we can
distribute it over the two numbers
inside of this expression so when we're
multiplying it times this entire
expression we can multiply 1 minus 3i
times 2 and 1 minus 3i times 5i so let's
do that so this can be re-written as 1
minus 3i times 2 times 2 I'll write the
2 out front plus 1 minus 3i plus 1 minus
3i times 5i times 5i all I did is the
distributive property here all I said is
look if I have a times B plus C this is
the same thing as a B plus AC I just
distributed I just distributed the a on
the B or the C I distributed the 1 minus
3i on the 2 and the 5 I and then I can
do it again I have a 2 now times 1 minus
3i I can distribute it 2 times 2 times 1
is 2 2 times negative 3i is negative 6i
and over here I'll do it again 5i times
1 so it's plus 5i times 1 is 5 I and
then 5i times negative 3i so let's be
careful here 5 times negative 3 so let
me just 5 times negative 3 is negative
15 negative 15 and then I have an I
times and I write I'm multiplying five
let me do this over here 5i times
negative 3i that's the same thing as 5
times negative 3 times I times I so the
five times negative
three is negative 15 and then we have I
times I which is I I squared now we know
what I squared is by definition I
squared is negative 1 I squared by
definition is negative 1 so you have
negative 15 times negative 1 well that's
the same thing as positive 15 so this
can be rewritten as 2 minus 6i plus 5i
negative 15 times negative 1 is positive
15 now we can add the real parts we have
a 2 and we have a positive 15 so 2 plus
15 and we can add the imaginary parts we
have a negative 6 so we have a negative
6 or negative 6i I should say and then
we have plus 5i so plus 5i + 2 + 15 is
17 and if I have negative 6 of something
plus 5 of that something what do I have
if I have 5 that's something and I take
6 of that something away then I have
negative 1 of that something negative 6i
plus 5i is negative 1 I or I could just
say minus I so in this way I just
multiplied these two expressions or
these two complex numbers really I
multiplied them just using the
distributive property twice you could
also do it using foil and I'll do that
right now really fast it is a little bit
faster but it's a little bit mechanical
so you might forget why you're doing it
in the first place but at the end of the
day you are doing the same thing here
you're essentially multiplying every
term of this first number or every part
of this first number times every part of
the second number and foil just make
sure that we're doing it and let me just
write foil out here which I'm not a huge
fan of but I'll do it just in case
that's the way you're learning it so
foil says let's do the first numbers
let's multiply the first numbers so
that's going to be the 1 times the 2 so
1 times the 2 that is the F in foil then
it says let's multiply the outer numbers
times each other so that's 1 times 5i so
plus 1 times 5i this is the eoghan foil
the outer numbers then we do the inner
numbers negative 3i times 2 so the
is negative 3i times 2 this is those are
the inner numbers and then we do the
last numbers negative 3i times 5 is so
negative 3i times 5i these are the last
numbers and that's all that foil is
telling us it's just making sure we're
multiplying every part of this number
times every part of that number and then
when we simplify it 1 times 2 is 2 1
times 5i is 5i negative 3i times 2 is
negative 6i and negative 3i times 5i
well we already figured with that we
already figured out what that was
negative 3i times 5i turns out to be 15
negative 3 times 5 is negative 15 but I
times I is negative 1 negative 15 times
negative 1 is positive positive 15 add
to the real parts 2 plus 15 you get 17
added the imaginary parts you have 5i
minus 6i you get negative I and once
again you get the exact same answer